welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Vossen Black Widow released a final
trailer that shows everyone doing their
best Russian accents and taskmaster
doing his best black panther impression
will kondo forever that is my line or
don't curve Oh son of a [ __ ]
while this taskmaster mysteries that
really keeping us scratching our heads
this trailer actually conceals a way
bigger reveal about who I think is a
true villain to this film and how it'll
connect the future properties on the MCU
calendar let's break this all down frame
by frame and spoiler warning in case you
like to complain let's get started I
tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher you're thinking
about moving but you're gonna waits
until the interest rates go down that's
not my story
okay the trailer opens on this landscape
of a shimmering coastline now every
trailer so far is open on a different
location first was Budapest
then it was Tel Aviv and now I'm
thinking Norway you can see a car
approaching to the far right and then
Natasha moves through this trailer home
and she passes this towel now I spent
way too much time figuring out what this
is actually a vintage Scandinavian tea
towel a recipe for happiness four cups
are all full cups of loyalty three cups
of forgiveness one cup of friendship
postponed to home to support a
tenderness four quarts of faith one
barrel a bottle after take love loyalty
mix early wood faith blend / tenderness
kindness and understanding that
friendship and hope and sprinkle
abundantly will after baked or sunshine
stir daily with generous help yeah how
much kindness and understanding they
weren't the ingredients towel anyway
it's Scandinavian so yeah Norway anyway
I'm just curious as to why this is the
first Racine of this location and all of
the promo footage could it be a
post-credits scene internet and even
secret er location the word secret er
looks like secretor nahi hain tana
yelena says that she tells people
natasha is a science teacher married to
a guy who renovates houses now natasha
ain't married the Hulk but the guy can
definitely flip a house now to be clear
by sister yelena considers natasha a
surrogate sister saying for when Alexi
later tells Natasha listen to your
mother
it's a surrogate family made up of these
Russian soldiers but it is interesting
that an end game Natasha wouldn't tell
cap before her Avengers family she had
nothing when she's got a family here and
why not delete super Captain America's
Civil War she mentioned visiting her
parents grades but I got a big juicy
theory for these inconsistencies that
I'll get to later but moving on Bryan
was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
a lot of enemies
Natasha's car gets a lit up on a bridge
you slow down you can see that it's a
red glowing beam or projectile that
causes his explosion perhaps one of
those explosive tipped arrows that we
see taskmaster using later in the
trailer and as Natasha roles you can see
some canister tumbling around in the
backseat now on the other promo footage
Natasha can be seen clutching these red
vials that I've speculated look a lot
like Pym particle vials they really look
like him on that Funko pop figurine and
perhaps she keeps those vials in this
canister and that's what test masters
after set photos have shown - Tasha
wading through water holding a similar
object scraps she gets away from
taskmaster by jumping off this bridge
and waiting to safety now Pym particles
will probably mean time Medlin I got a
theory for that but these vials could be
something else perhaps the means by
which the other Black Widow agents get
mind-controlled so by controlling these
red things they keep this mind
controlled assassins from doing really
bad things
taskmaster pulls a cap or a falcon and
discus tosses the shield at Natasha now
if you were to enhance the other promo
footage of taskmaster swinging on that
bridge you can make out what looks like
an actual spider-man piece of webbing
this guy has got it all we see more of
his process in the next clip is called
Stein's taskmaster he controls the Red
Room there manipulated fully conscious
with no choices
so apparently taskmasters power comes
from the same place my power does
obsessive in here he's watching footage
of Natasha from iron man 2 it's actually
the same security footage that whiplash
was watching during that scene you think
about it caps elevator shield move was
also on security camera footage at
Sidwell watched and spider-man's moves
were all on you too so everything
taskmaster knows he got from a past MCU
moment that was recorded a close-up of
his mask shows a circular piece that
could be a camera lense traps this is
how he records everything he sees in in
that eyepiece you can see projections
what appear to amount to an internal
heads-up display I don't like what I
earn man has in his helmet so maybe
taskmasters famous viewer combat ability
is less photographic reflexes than like
a supercomputer analyzing combat tactics
now taskmasters identity remains
concealed so let's break down all the
suspects we've mentioned from most
likely to most fun the likely direction
is the comics identity of Tony masters
perhaps a double identity of ot Tech Ben
Lee's character Mason since no promo
footage has shown the actor whatsoever
taskmaster appears to be taller than
other characters as expect Ben Lee and
the actor recently posted on Instagram
with the caption hashtag TM so there you
go
but now that we're learning the Red Room
Black Widow agents are being
mind-controlled
it's also possible taskmaster could be a
shared identity screen style and
characters like Molina or Elena could at
times be under that hood mask like
taskmaster Molina and Yelena share
mirrored fight moves to Natasha other
options that have been brought up our
Hawkeye Clint Barton who does of the
past in Budapest and could be being
pressured by people like Ross say by
kidnapping his family or Bucky who yeah
has it passed as a mind-control
terrorist an assassin I have also
speculated that Zemo could be under that
mask as a close Avengers observer who
could also be doing Ross's bidding since
they have mutual enemies whoever
taskmaster is I have a feeling that he
is controlling the Red Room assets on
behalf of Ross now if we were to
interpret those red vials ads Pym
particles taskmaster could be Natasha
herself from a different times if you
think about it when she fell off that
cliff in Vermeer she did have one
remaining Pym particle there was a flash
of light she could have zipped back
through time got a bunch of other Pym
particles and then gone on one
last time mission to write all of our
past wrongs before coming back and
closing the loop to die fun but yeah
probably
OTE equals to you know notice here that
Yelena has a nasty cut on her arm when
the previous shot it was bandaged I'm
guessing that this is after their knife
fight maybe now natasha has stitching
her up over beers in a restaurant where
people are eating um excuse me can you
do that in a bathroom oh wow
we left our recipe for happiness privacy
towel at home okay deal with it
natasha says she regrets not going back
for Yelena but then there's this
overhead shot as if it's a flashback but
it ain't a flashback that white jumpsuit
Yelena wears probably sets this after
other events in the movie and this
medical procedure seems like the biggest
reveal of the trailer look folks I'm
spending all this time in the blue
dungeon breaking stuff down because I'm
not the biggest fan of surprises
surprises scare me surprises like the
hidden fee so just pop up on my bank
statement true jumpscared well banking
fees are a thing of the past with
current and thanks to current for
sponsoring this video so current is a
mobile bank account that comes with a
Visa debit card that has no minimum
balance no overdraft no hidden fees the
black premium card gets you paid up to
two days faster when you move your
direct deposit to current so if you
normally get paid on Fridays that means
with current your paycheck hits
Wednesdays current gives you a bank
account in a real debit card without all
the fees and requirements of old banks
and sketchy prepaid cards you can
connect your current card to cash app or
venmo get cash back at the register and
deposit checks into your account using
your camera the premium account has
perks like instantly refunding the holds
at gas stations put on your card at the
pump the app notifies you when you spend
automatically helps you put away money
with savings pods and as 24/7 support
through live chat plus current even has
bank accounts for teens if you're under
18 current works with Apple pay and
Google pay on your phone and it's
available in the US it only takes two
minutes to sign up and your current card
will be shipped to you for free download
current now at the link in the
description below okay I need to talk
about two things from this shot of
Yelena the equipment or side appears to
be marked with the acronym a IM AOL
instantly just kidding aim advanced idea
mechanics it's the marvel scientific
research agency that was last mentioned
in Iron Man 3 the organization founded
by Aldrich Killian
rose up to shadowy stuff like the
extremists program so what are they
doing with the alena here oh look at her
face there is a
line drawn around her hairline guys I
prepped us up jokingly before but is
Yelena seriously getting her face
surgically swapped this wouldn't be the
craziest thing to happen because in the
2001 breakdown storyline
Natasha definitely swaps faces with
Yelena in order to get closer to Yelena
is handler general fil Yanko to prevent
a nuclear disaster and to show you Elena
how much stilyaga hates are ordered to
turn her against him now here Yelena is
strapped down forced into this operation
come on well maybe after Natasha
disappears goes off the grid
Ross could take Yelena and use medical
technology from aim to reconstruct
Elena's face to look like Natasha's why
this is cool also to get an asset close
to the fugitives he's after cap and
Bucky Ross's broader goal could be to
have a Natasha Romanov under his control
and to use the same taskmaster
brainwashing technology to assemble his
own Avengers team that he calls the
Thunderbolts initiative this face swap
could explain the Tasha's mysterious
hair color changed to blonde when we
catch back up with her an infinity war
and why Natasha is wearing the same
exact best that Yelena wears in this
movie it could be why Natasha claims to
have never had a true family an in-game
and while she claims to have not known
her father's name books we could really
be looking at a reality where the
Natasha and infinity war an endgame was
not the real Natasha Romanov but instead
this Yelena imposter and that could be
the one who died and our real Natasha
could still be alive ready to come back
for future MCU films
maybe with scar Joe's face or maybe with
for interviews face whichever actress is
more affordable yeah and this Ross aim
connection could also pave the way for
where I think his characters headed Red
Hawk in the world war a hoax comic
storyline aim is the agency partially
behind Ross's transformation if the MCU
is bringing aim back Ross as Red Hulk
seems like a very interesting goal I've
given you a lot to think about so let's
move on to the next section
in us
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
okay Natasha and yelena flee the other
red room agents and then this rural home
that the family appears in later it's
now swarmed by taskmasters aircrafts now
these things are all over the poster for
the movie I'm diggin they might play a
big role in the story perhaps there's
some plot to deploy these mind
controlled agents via this fleet to
locations all over the world in a
coordinated mass assassination Natasha
appears in a room looking through holo
projected screens that seems show maps
like that looks like Southeast Asia on
the left maybe perhaps she's uncovering
this plot moving on with you
you won't win of course not the best
okay past this section red Guardian
faces taskmaster who does the Black
Panther Claw move followed by a
spider-man style kick and backflip but
mostly I'm interested in how taskmaster
got the vibranium for these claws abs he
got it from claws stolen stash or notice
this shot of the Red Room agents the one
on the left has some interesting scar
tissue on her cheeks not sure what
caused this but maybe it's tribal
scarring like the kind we saw from some
of the tribes of Wakanda in black
panther if you look closely at these
female assassins there is a lot of
ethnic diversity it's almost as if
there's one for every major country
perhaps the Red Room has a sleeper cell
assassin for every one of their targets
including Wakanda ready to drop in and
take out the leader of that country as
part of this coordinated assassination
and this wakandan spy could be how
taskmaster got access to that vibranium
onto the next clip plan what's it drive
us away Blair your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose okay
they talked to me Elena flee through the
streets of Budapest from taskmasters
tank vehicle and explosive arrows and
then Natasha fights off several Black
Widow agents in this fancy room now we
have seen this in other promo footage I
think it's a main command centre for the
Red Room because the painting on the
reverse wall showing Rasputin the
infamous mystic healer and adviser to
the final Russian royal family of
emperor Tsar Nicholas the second before
the Revolution now the quick cuts in
chaotic camera movement make it hard to
tell but this room is streaked with red
light
perhaps it's the projection of these
world maps as the screens are shattering
to create a really cool lighting effect
where the targeted countries that are at
stake are projecting on these characters
as they fight moving on
[Music]
and me my choice
okay here there's some great action but
the big takeaway is this shot of Ross
where is this and more importantly when
is this he's using a cane so this could
be around the time Ross said he suffered
his heart attack which would have been
around 2011 five years ago I had a heart
attack
I'm dropped right in the middle of my
backswing turned out it was the best
round of my life because after 13 hours
of surgery and a triple bypass
I found something forty years in the
Army and never taught me perspective but
2011 was not long after we saw Ross than
the Incredible Hulk when his hair and
moustache were gray and here he looks
noticeably D aged fewer wrinkles blonder
hair like what William Hurt looked like
in the late 90s so why does a younger
Ross need a cane maybe it's just an old
army injury and all of his scenes are
flashbacks but if Natasha Romanov would
be in those scenes Scarlett Johansson
was a teenager in the late 90s well
maybe that surgery in perspective that
Ross mentioned was actually a medical
procedure that gave him a transfusion of
gamma-irradiated blood from his aim
buddies causing his physical appearance
to fluctuate one moment he's got a
youthful complexion and hair cuts the
other he's got an occasional limp the
next he's hulking out cherry-flavored
moving on honey
here red Guardium proves his own shield
mastery kickflips it just like
taskmaster did and cap before him and
then he frisbees that passed Molina out
the cockpit window do clobber this dude
and by the looks of it huh come into the
jet engine this appears to be part of
the big climax of the film what's really
going on here well there's a shot of
Yelena piloting a craft and behind her
in the Far background appears to be some
giant structure it's been built with
cranes all of the trailer footage has
been very careful to hide whatever this
is
except of course some shots of it
collapsing and falling apart leading to
the epic skydive fight between Natasha
and taskmaster the piece of debris that
they slide against looks like it's made
of these high-tech cells maybe like a
solar panel or maybe want to be
reflective panels that lie in
Helicarrier and allow it to add that
cloaking effect so could this
construction be an attempt by Ross to
build his own fleet of helicarriers
kind of like his own project in sight
that he's trying to build on foreign
soil without Nick Fury knowing or could
this all be the early stages of a peak
space station under sword feel like all
these trailers have been coming out with
a camera pointed away from a giant Death
Star being built behind us let me know
what you think this is as we move on to
the final clip here's what's gonna
happen
Natasha don't sit slouch I'm not
slouching you're going to get the back
hunched listen to mother oh all of you I
didn't say anything that's not fair
Oh looks like all this family needs to
do is read from a certain tea towel and
Natasha the recipe for happiness does
not have slouching as an ingredient go
to your room young lady who do you make
- master is why when Natasha and Yelena
swap faces and what the hell is that
structure comment down below and for
more of our Marvel theories and
speculation be sure to join our official
discord server where we chew on all this
stuff with our inner circle of
supporters access our discord by
becoming a patron of new rock starts
today at patreon.com slash new rock
stars although Mia da vas follow new
rock stars and subscribed into rock
stars or breakdowns of everything Marvel
thanks for watching bye
[Music]